you
[Music]
our speaker today is rush me when I
crush means visiting us from CMU where
she's a professor of computer science in
the computer science department rush me
is done a lot of interesting work at the
intersection of network systems and
coding theory I find a lot of our ideas
to be super creative and if you know
when you read that work or hear about it
at least for me it puts a smile on my
face so rationally were super excited to
have you here she's not a stranger to
MSR
as a student at Berkeley you know she
she also interned here twice twice she
was recipient of the PhD fellowship
she'll be talking to us about some work
that is not just related storage systems
but also said if influence workloads and
this is work I guess done with two of my
other favorite color you know
collaborators Jack who's here this
summer was rationing student and Chevron
who used to be with us with us here last
year so but commercial thanks for the
kind introduction Amer hi everyone it's
always good to be back here at MSR
before going into the talk I will just
quickly give you all a flavor of the
kind of research that my group at CMU
does so I called my group F thesis
standing for theory and systems because
we do research both in theory and in
systems with the tight synergistically
loop between the two so we formulate
theoretical problems based on real world
system challenges and take the insights
from the theoretically optimal solutions
that we arrive it and take it back into
the systems world to build real world
systems that significantly advance the
state of the art so on the on the theory
side we mainly work on problems and
information and coding theory
specifically on what are called erasure
codes or also known as error correcting
codes we also use tools from probability
and statistics on the system side our
group is mainly interested in
reliability and predictable performance
in
large scale systems we are looking at
various kinds of systems and
applications including storage systems
machine learning systems content
distribution networks and live streaming
today's talk is about redundancy in
large-scale systems large-scale systems
are often prone to non ideal operating
conditions such as failures stragglers
load imbalance and so on and redundancy
is a common approach to impart
resilience against such situations in
large-scale systems so for example in a
data processing system it could be
duplicating queries or in a storage
system it is duplicating data while
redundancy helps in imparting resilience
it comes with a cost
right so redundancy would often require
additional hardware resources which
requires increased cost in buying those
equipment increased power to operate
them increase cooling and more
operations and overall significantly
additional cost for the system so it's
important to introduce this redundancy
in a resource efficient manner so in
this talk I'll have two parts in the
first in the first part I'll talk about
resource efficient redundancy in data
processing systems specifically in
prediction serving systems basically
systems that take already trained
machine learning models and serve
inference for queries and in the second
part I'll talk about resource efficient
redundancy in distributed storage
systems specifically large scale cluster
storage systems in both of these parts
I'll draw tools from coding Theory
machine learning or data analysis and
also blend them with system insights ok
so let's get into the first part of the
talk on resource efficient redundancy
for prediction serving systems so this
is hot off the press we are currently
working on
ready version for the CAS OSP this is a
joint work with my PhD student Jack who
is right here and she rom was at
wisconsin-madison jack is really the
main workhorse behind this work so when
machine learning is used in production
systems there are two phases right so
there is training and there is inference
so during training one there's iterative
optimization or the data and arrives at
a model right
and then during inference this already
learned model is used to serve inference
on queries so for example a query could
be an image of a dog and the model is
for example could be an image classifier
and the prediction would be the class of
that image the platforms that deployed
such learned models and serve queries
curve inference on these queries are
called prediction serving systems and
now given the rise in the use of machine
learning in various applications there
are several prediction serving systems
both in the open source world as well as
which are offered as cloud services
including at Microsoft so at a high
level the architecture of prediction
serving systems includes several servers
running these already trained models
that are called model instances and
typically a particular model is run on
different model they on different
servers in order to serve high query
throughput and then often there is a
front-end which takes in the queries
from the clients sends them to these
model instances and once the inference
is ready it is collected and given back
to the clients so these predictions
serving systems often fall into the
critical path between the applications
and the end-users and hence it is
important to meet service level latency
agreements and also operate with really
low predictable latency
and like any other service they face
slowdowns and failures that are common
in a cloud operation or a cluster
operation due to various reasons and
hence these can result in inflated tail
agencies and there is interest in
minimizing the tail latency in such
systems so there are various solutions
to minimizing teh latency in such
systems and they can be broadly
classified into two categories so one of
them is what I'll call reactive that is
in which we can send a query to a server
and wait for some time and then retry if
we don't get back the response in time
so we could send query to server one and
if it is slow or maybe fail then retry
it on another server after waiting for
certain time so the main problem with
these kind of solutions
is that we have to wait so they are
reactive so you wait for a certain time
before issuing the second request so
there is a delay in the mitigation for
this increased latency so the other
class of solutions is what I'll call
replicative which is more proactive that
is issuing requests proactively to
multiple servers so we could in the same
scenario we could send the query
simultaneously to multiple servers and
then take the response from the one
which comes first so if one of the
service is slow we can take back the
prediction that comes from the other
server so the problem with this class of
solutions is that they require more
resources so in this example you need at
least 2x more resources right so if we
look at this cartoon plot where I have
recovery delay on the y-axis and
resource overhead on the x-axis so lower
is better on the y-axis and left or
lower value is better on the x-axis so
the reactive approaches are low on
resource our head because you issue a
redundant query only when needed but the
recovery delay is higher right and for
replicative solutions this also worried
is
because they are proactive but the
recovery delay is small so in this part
of the talk I'm interested in seeing how
we can enable in between points and we
are going to do this wire a tool called
arrays arrays decoded computation so
I'll now next quickly give a primer on
what a ratio coding is and what a ratio
coded computation is and then see how to
use it in prediction serving systems and
what are the challenges and what are our
solutions to address them so a very
quick primer on erasure coding so you
might have already heard about this and
know about this necessarily in that case
it will help in you know setting the
terminology and we come onto the same
page so it's a resource efficient way of
adding redundancy and I'll use storage
as an example to illustrate this concept
so let's say we have two disks disc 1
and s 2 storing D 1 and D 2 and let's
say our goal is to add resilience
against a single disk failure so a
simple approach for doing this is
replication that is you have two copies
of this data so if one of the disk fails
there is another copy so we are all good
right however here 50% of the total
resources are being consumed for
redundancy now the same goal can be
achieved using airasia coding in the
following manner so instead of having
four disks in total now we will have
only three disks so we have data D 1 and
D 2 and we create what is called a
parity which is just an XOR of D 1 and D
2 and these are stored in these three
disks so now if a single disk fails that
data can be recovered by just
subtracting or frozen eggs or just
ignoring the parity and the other data
that is there so we have achieved the
same fault tolerance the single disk
fault tolerance with only 33 percent of
the total resources being used for
redundancy
so in general it is well known that
arisia course achieve desired level of
resilience with much lower resource
overhead so in general you can have K
Delta units and that case encoded to
create our parity units right in the
example we had we are two data units and
one parity so here in general you can
have K and R
and when decoding you can take any k out
of the k plus R units and then you can
decode to get back the original K data
units and also I'd like to note one
general characteristics of most of the
codes employed in practice is are what
are called linear codes specifically
what it means is that the parity units
that are formed are linear combinations
or linear functions of the data units
and this will come up later in the talk
okay so this was about erasure coding
now what is it is recorded computation
so now consider this scenario where we
have multiple copies of a function f
that are being computed on different
nodes and now let x1 and x2 be the
inputs and f of x1 and f of x2 are the
corresponding function outputs now
suppose we want to add resilience now
against slow or failed servers not the
disks in like in the previous examples
but now the servers being slow and now
we want to add resilience to get back
the function outputs and not the date
okay so in how can we do this using
tools from a recording so in this
scenario what one would do is you create
encoding of the queries the inputs x1
and x2 and create a parity input B and
there is a redundant computation unit
which operates on this parity and if one
of the original function units are
unavailable you could decode the output
of that function by using the outputs of
the
once and the redundant computation so
let me just contrast between storage and
this to highlight the differences so in
storage we wanted to add resilience
against disk failures and we want to
recover the data right whereas in when
using a ratio coding for computation we
want to add resilience against the
failure of servers and we want to
recover the function outputs not the
original data and in order to add
resilience when we want to recover the
data as you recall we encoded the data
and stored the parity and then if one of
the disks is unavailable or failed we
recover it by doing ricans this decoding
or reconstruction on the data itself now
when using a ratio coding for
computation
on the other hand we are encoding the
inputs and processing it through a
redundant computation unit and when the
output one of the outputs is unavailable
the decoding is performed on the
function outputs not on the original
data encoding is done on the data but
decoding is done on the function outputs
in contrast to in data storage yeah
that's a very good question so it so
I'll talk about different approaches it
could be same or it could be different I
think it will become more clear as we go
yeah yeah it's a very good point so it's
not necessarily F it could be different
I think I forgot to change this F after
changing it yeah it seems that you would
know to calculate this ferret you would
want to enumerate the inputs you could
have and try to match that yeah yeah
mm-hm and it seems hard and that
starting to
for possible in a very good question so
this is where the some of the challenges
that I will talk about when using this
specifically in the domain of you know
collection serving systems we're coming
yeah so there are in some cases where
you don't have to enumerate which is
where it's easier and when in which case
it's you know like it will work with
existing codes and in other scenarios as
you mentioned where this enumeration
would not be it's not a parade yeah so
there are some kind of structures where
enumeration is not needed that's where
the linearity will come in so I'll go
into that okay so now a very good
question so I think leading to that so
question is when will such a
reconstruction work right so we are
encoding the queries and but decoding on
the output of the functions so linear
functions commute with linear courts so
recall that in a linear code the
parities are linear combinations of the
data units so if you have a linear
function f then the encoding and the
decoding will commute with the linear
operations so let's just take a quick
example so let's say f of X is 2x which
is a linear function and we want to
operate this F on different servers
let's x1 and x2 are the two inputs and
we create a parity which is just sum of
x1 and x2 so now we send it to these
servers and let's say one of them is low
so now we can recover F of x2 by just
subtracting the function outputs on the
parity input and F of x1 so this all
works out and we get back the right
output this is because f of X is linear
and our encoding is also linear right so
this actually is the scenario where you
don't have to enumerate the inputs
because of the linearity okay however
the key challenge is actually in
handling nonlinear functions so and
let's
why doesn't work out right so let's take
a simple example where f of X is e to
the X and let's take the same scenario
as earlier we have three copies of e to
the X on different servers and X 1 and X
2 all inputs and we create the same
parity X 1 plus X 2 and now when we send
them through these functions and let's
say again the second server is slow now
if we try to do the same decoding F of F
of P minus f of X 1 we don't get back
the correct output ok so so this was
about a recorded computation and an
inherent challenge in handling
non-linearity so there have been a lot
of related work in the domain of coded
computation in fact coded computation
for tolerating hardware fault failures
has been looked at a few decades ago and
it was only recently that Liat all
introduced coded computation in the
distributed computation context and
specifically for distributed matrix
vector multiplication problem and since
then there has been a large body of work
on coded computation and this is where
going and a very exciting field in the
domain of coded computation or in the
domain of coded coding theory right now
however oh so before going into that so
let me just put this in context so let's
see when we are using coded computation
in prediction serving systems what does
it mean right so now in a prediction
serving system the function f is going
to be machine learning model and many of
the state-of-the-art machine learning
models are now neural networks right so
we are going to have let's say a neural
network as a function and now inputs are
going to be queries so you'd be encoding
queries and performing a redundant
computation which would be another model
and then if one of them is unavailable
you would decode the outputs from the
original
model and what comes along the redundant
path and the goal would be to
reconstruct what is unavailable yeah so
however the key challenge here is that
many of the state-of-the-art machine
learning models are neural networks and
neural networks are highly nonlinear so
within neural networks between the
layers the matrix vector multiplication
that happens is linear but end to end it
is nonlinear because of the nonlinear
activation functions right and as we saw
it's challenging to handle general
nonlinear functions in this coded
computation framework in fact existing
coded computation schemes are applicable
only for a limited class of functions
and specifically linear and polynomial
functions and more importantly efficient
schemes are known only for linear
functions for example in the case of
polynomials even a degree two polynomial
requires overhead more than full
replication so our solution to tackle
this problem is to use machine learning
along with coding so basically we
propose using a learning based approach
in designing the coded computation
framework so basically learn various
components of the coded computation
framework for example we have this
encoder decoder and the redundant
computation unit right so there are two
approaches towards this and one of the
natural approaches is to keep this
rendering computation unit same as the
original function and this actually
conforms to the traditional coded
computation frameworks and learn only
the encoder and decoder so this is
basically like learning a code you learn
the encoder and the decoder and that's
what we called it like learning a code
so a little bit of details on this so
basically now the encoder and the
decoder
I learned using a neural network and the
encoder takes K queries as inputs in
this example K is 2 and it outputs our
parity queries and in this example R is
1 and similarly decoder would take K
inputs which are predictions from these
models right so in this context and the
output would be our unavailable
predictions so how do we train these
neural networks which are encoders and
decoders so the training data set use
are same as the original model training
data and we mimic stragglers or failures
by artificially erasing the outputs from
these functions when training and the
back propagate through the original
model so I'll take a concrete example to
go through this so let's take F as an
image classifier neural network and
let's choose K equal to 2 and R equal to
1 that is we are encoding 2 queries and
creating single parity query so these
two are the original models and let's
say this is the redundant model so
recall that in this approach redundant
model is same as the original model so
this is the blue neural network and we
have the encoder and the decoder these
are the new neural networks that need to
be trained so let's take X 1 and X 2
these are the two training images just
picked at random from the training data
set and we pass it through the original
models first and it is also sent through
the encoder because encoder acts on
these queries right and the output of
the encoder is passed through this
redundant model and during training we
will erase one of the outputs of the two
original models and the decoder acts on
the remaining two and it outputs a
vector which represents the final
you're vector so if in this example this
if this is an image classification model
right so the this vector will have value
such that you know the maximum value
corresponds to the predicted class of
the image yeah is it some function of x1
x2 that gets fed in as one equal to it
is taking two in this case yeah so since
K is 2 so the encoder takes two images
as input and so for example right so
right so for example if it was a
pre-designed code like that's the
handcrafted code for example let's say
just single parity x1 plus x2 then it
would be taking x1 and x2 as inputs it's
the same okay so this is the forward
pass right and now since this is
training we know what F of x2 should
have been right so we can take some loss
function whatever it is appropriate take
the Delta function and propagate it back
through the original model but the
original model is not modified because
that's the same as the you know whatever
model is deployed only the encoder and
the decoder weights are updated during
this back propagation class yeah
gibberish yes
so is that also included in the S so
what do you mean by included for example
F of oh okay so you only the image yes
output output after decoding right okay
so so after decoding in this scenario
when the output of the second model is
unavailable you expect F of x2 yeah each
of the models on the left are speeding
our classes and the one on the right is
perhaps really now I guess some classes
because
the same type right yes so all of them
are giving F of the so we are taking the
final nail class each of those is the
output in our class yes so think of it
as a vector when you do an Arg max on
this so the odd max output will be a
class yes exactly so okay so yeah so we
are not taking just the class output
because that loses a lot of information
so we're taking the vector the last
layer vector as they right okay yeah so
basically using the same training data
set as the original model and mimicking
stragglers are failures by artificially
erasing the outputs from the models and
back propagating through the original
model so this training method is
applicable for any numerically
differentiable function f so and this is
a broad class of functions because all
the machine learning models for example
that are trained on the leg platforms
are numerically differentiable so this
learning a core approach is really the
first coded computation approach that
enabled doing color computation or in
this broad class of nonlinear functions
and it was also the first work that
proposed and enabled use of coded
computation for prediction serving
systems so previously the works on coded
computation that looked at machine
learning the focus was more on training
however it has its downsides when we
look at it from a systems perspective so
in order to understand the downsides
let's go back to this architecture of
prediction serving systems and see how
it how it would be incorporated into
this model and then we can see the
downsides very clearly so so recall that
in a prediction serving system typically
you have a front end and you have model
instances being run on different servers
so a natural place where the encoder and
the decoder of this coded computation
approach would fit and is at the front
end whereas the queries come in they are
dispatched to the model instances and
they are also sent to the encoder and
the encoder output is dispatched to
another model instance and as the
predictions arrive they are sent back to
the clients and if any one of them are
slower unavailable then you could use
the output from the parity query and
then decode and then send it back so the
mean the yeah there's a constraint on
how fast the decoder has to be right it
has to be much faster than yeah yes yeah
so that's yeah I'll come to that so that
absolutely yeah so so one of the
downsides here is is that you know we
need a bulkier front-end because now the
neural network encoding and decoding has
to happen at the front end right and
also as you just mentioned this has
reduced opportunity for improving tail 8
& C because the redundant path that is
which goes through the encoder the
original model and the decoder now takes
a lot more time because you're doing
neural network encoding a neural network
decoding which takes a lot of time so
and these these downsides pushed us to
explore further on this learning based
coded computation and we arrived at
another approach which we call learning
parity models which is basically so we
keep the encoder and the decoder very
simple so it could be for example a
generic encoder and a decoder such as
just doing subtraction addition or
subtraction or a task specific but still
simple encoder and decoder for example
for an image classification it could be
just downsizing and concatenation I'll
go into details of this later but
keeping the encoder and the decoder very
simple so very low time right but
earning a new model for the redundant
computation so not keeping the redundant
computation same as the original model
so and this new model is what we call as
a parity model so let's see now how the
training of a parity model would would
look like and this is very similar to
what I described earlier in learning a
code so we used again the same training
data set as the original model and
mimicked stragglers and failures by you
know just deleting the function outputs
when we are training let's again take a
very concrete example as seen earlier
image classifier function and k equal to
two are equal to 1 that is encoding two
queries creating a single parity query
and for this example I will assume
generic encoder and decoder that is just
addition as an encoder and subtraction
as the decoder okay so now yeah do the
encoder the original images or some
visual map it's the same it's like the
original images yeah so yeah it will be
making some values yes so it will be
clear yeah so so these are the two
original neural networks image
classifiers and I have to because k
equal to 2 and now this is the parity
model so now we call now that unlike the
original the first approach now this is
a new neural network that needs to be
trained so this is the read neural
network map yeah usually is the
structure of that water the same as is
it good architecture search in that
space
very good question the it could be
different but in this example I'm using
the same and in the evaluation that I'm
going to show we use the same same
architecture and we are just learning
the weights but you know there's nothing
preventing in the framework to use a
different model and in fact it could be
useful and it can help in improving the
accuracy using a completely different
model
is that then you have to somehow tell it
the cost for this model also ought to be
is it exactly yes it must be bounded by
the course like the inference cost of
that yes should be like an opportunity
order tonight maybe slightly do it
because you have addition thing yeah so
basically you would want to choose a
network which has a similar time lightly
no latency as the original model yes
yeah right right okay cool so just as a
quick recap we have k equal to two are
equal to one two original networks and
one parity model that needs to be
trained and as I mentioned in this
example I'll assume the generic simple
early edition encoder and a subtraction
decoder as before we pick two images
from the data set at random and send it
through the original models for Clah
which are the blue neural networks and
also send it through this addition
encoder and now the output of this
simple encoder is sent as an input to
the parity model and during training you
arrays one of the outputs and the
remaining that are existing outputs from
these models are sent to the decoder
which is just a subtraction decoder and
we again have this F hat of x2 and this
is the forward pass and since we since
this is training we know F of x2 and we
can take a loss function on this and
propagate the loss back and in the this
time we are changing the weights of this
parity model which is what we are
learning yeah
this is one way of putting a smiley yeah
so the parity model is it if you can you
think about it as a more powerful
version of the original model in the
sense that you can do all right so why
don't I just replace my original model
mm-hmm with replicas of the parity model
mm-hmm Oh No soso this is actually doing
a different so this is a new learning
task as I'll briefly mention later more
powerful than the other so it is doing a
similar learning task like image
classification but a harder task so
basically now the input is an addition
and then it it is harder why because now
we have this x1 plus x2 as inputs and
what it kind of has to do is
simultaneously do if you look at this
subtraction decoder what kind of you're
expecting the parity model to give out
as output is f of x1 plus f of x2 right
so it's it kind of has to classify both
simultaneously
yes exactly yeah it is not yes so you
can think of it this way right so there
is so when this parity model is trying
to get its outputs when it is looking
let's say at x1
the other input so in this example x2 is
like noise right so if so there is the
signal to noise ratio phenomenon that is
happening so as you add more and more it
becomes harder and harder functionally
the same architecture mm-hmm
that seems you buy that this model was
which is all proteins I'm innocent it's
this a limit to how much so you mean
when you say when you're saying the
model is over prohibition basically so
you might not need those many layers on
I see mm-hmm yes Samar right yeah that's
a that's a very good that's a very good
point and that is why I think having
neural architecture search or a better
architecture for parity metal model can
can help in getting better accuracy yes
yes many of these functions are that's
just yeah yeah that's a very good point
yes yeah yep do you see this a bound on
the cage in a soldier because at some
point you'd end up you know
yes yeah exactly so as I was mentioning
as we add more and more it gets harder
and we will see that you know that I
will go into the accuracy evaluation and
there's more details in the paper it the
accuracy drops as we increase K right
for this but exactly the same reason
yeah but currently we don't have a good
fundamental understanding of where the
bound is yeah it would be very
interesting to you know study that that
further to understand it better yeah
yeah have you tried making
encoder/decoder we could do that yes
but we haven't done that yet here what
I'm going to show but what the it would
still have the downside which I
mentioned earlier because of the
requiring you know bulkier front-end and
the time required for the neural network
training for sorry not training when
you're going through the redundant path
you know that additional time would be
there but that's also feasible jointly
training everything yeah yeah yeah
possible yes yeah so as I'll briefly
mention later this actually opens up a
really rich design space there is lots
to explore and you know like you know
like even training methodologies and as
you know we had a very good comment
there that you know they could have
having a stronger model for the parity
model can help you know so there are a
lot of explorations to be done yet yeah
just just doing computation on both the
days and the famous episode right so
it's almost like they're taking two
networks there and they're putting there
and then computing both of them but it
is not right so it's not really doing
two networks but I mean network is
powerful enough fixes yeah so that's why
it like in in water talked about in the
evaluation it is the same it's the same
architecture same latency so you're not
using additional compute so even if you
look at it even if you go into the
simpler let's say so it's it's more
easier to look at it in the linear world
so it's because same thing is happening
here so for example if you if you had a
linear function then if you just if you
add the input and send it right even
there in a way it's acting on two inputs
like for example in this case yeah right
what is apparent amount of cooking is
outputting roughly there's the softmax
or the one hot encoding of a catalyst a
monkey today okay which means that the
output of the patty model already
contains enough information I already
know that these two images one of them
contains monkey just by looking at the
but in if you agree with the linear case
that's the same thing that's happening
it's not what is x1 and x2 I know F of
x1 I know F of F of x2 mm-hmm and they
know the XOR then it does not tell me
anything about it is because in the in
the in a in the linear case f of x1 plus
x2 is f of x1 plus f of x2 pieces like
so but in general it's not telling
anything it's all right like there are
two bits of information and I'm getting
only one bit of information from this
but here it's not that here it's not I'm
getting let's say this is
F of x1 is one bit of information f of X
this one yeah relation but this battery
model is all almost outputting to
disappear no it does not it is it is
still getting the same decoding now so
the length so if you think in parallel
for the linear case right the same thing
is happening here the length of the
vector the information that you're
talking about is a function of the
length of the vector right so if the
length of the vector is the same you
cannot give our more information the the
output that you're thinking about in the
linear case the same is happening here
but these vectors are supposed to be
like softmax so basically the output f
of x1 mm-hmm the vector is not really
really a compactor it's mostly like on
the cat it has is this zero right so
it's you should think of it as just you
know it's just an indicator backdrop
again roughly sure and this is the
indicator it's better of a monkey mm-hm
I want this is outputting he's
supposedly they indicate a regular cat
Plus yes so it's a plus so I think that
is very close yeah but it's giving a lot
more information now because I know it
has - yeah so we can chat more yeah but
it so if you think about linear case in
parallel it the same thing is happening
we can chat more more offline
oh yeah the key is that input to the
parity model is a song it doesn't have
access to x1 or x2 you only has I agree
with that so now what I'm saying is that
you don't need
imagine if the model is so powerful you
can just combine all the inputs and then
train it the output indicator vector and
so already know you're there I just need
to figure out what is what yeah but here
all the yeah we can chat offline but all
the inputs are not going in into the
parity model but we can track more yeah
okay
so so this the forward pass and the
backward pass and this is how you train
the parity model and we have implemented
this approach the second approach which
is the parity models approach which I
will denote as power M for gravity on
top of clipper which is an open source
prediction serving system and I know
Daniels here now yeah yeah ok the
encoder and the decoder we have
implemented it in the Clippers front end
and the original and the parity models
are all pi Tosh models and docker
containers
okay so first in the evaluation I'll go
into the evaluation of accuracy first
and then evaluation of latency so in
terms of evaluation of accuracy as we
were discussing earlier this is a new
learning task and so we evaluated it on
a variety of inference tasks and data
sets including image classification
speech recognition and
object localization and a variety of
popular neural network models and for
the encoder in the decoder
I'll show first mainly the most of the
results with the generic
addition/subtraction encoder and the
decoder which enables us to show the
applicability for a variety of tasks you
know on image speech and object
localization and also I'll briefly
mention about this inference task
specific encoder and decoder that is for
image classification for example you
could downsize and concatenate as an
encoder second one you don't change the
water you know no so the fact that we do
like the parity model is still trained
yeah but on both the cases the
architecture is in the evaluations is
the same okay so for looking at accuracy
so look at the overall accuracy as a
function of accuracy in the degraded
mode and we're in the normal mode so in
the normal mode I'll call the accuracy
as a subscript a that is when it is
available when everything is available
and in the degraded mode when some of
the original models may be unavailable
so fu is denotes the fraction of the
instances unavailable and a subscript D
is the degraded mode accuracy and this
part now represents the accuracy in the
normal mode that is when all the
original models are available so for the
matrix basically we would want to look
at available versus degraded mode
accuracy right so what is the accuracy
on the task when
model is when original model is
unavailable and also we'll look at
overall accuracy okay so in this plot
I'll be showing accuracy on the y-axis
in percentage and different data sets or
tasks on the x-axis so higher is better
so in all these in the initial set of
evaluations I'll use k equal to 2 or
equal to 1 that is 33% of the total
resources are being used for redundant
computation so here are these yellow
bars our accuracy when everything is
available this is basically original
model accuracy because the original
models are all available now in the
degraded mode that is when one of the
original models is not available these
blue bars are the accuracies that are
obtained by when using the output from
the parity model and then decoding so as
we can see for all these tasks we can
get pretty good accuracy within around
7% of the original model being available
what is fu so here this is just showing
when one of the original model is
unavailable so yeah so k equal to 2 are
equal to 1 and let's say yellow bar is
just what is available and then if one
of them is not available what is the
accuracy on the decoded out yeah yeah
yeah yeah
so we'll yeah so I'll use the fu
notation a little bit later so it won't
be used in this fear yeah yeah so
basically I'm specifically showing the
degraded mode yeah okay thank you
um true if you sew in different ways in
the sense that if you look at it as just
the accuracy on the task it is
significant right so even like a small
percentage loss is lost
yeah right exactly yeah but if you look
at it as this is the output when the
original model is not available right so
in that respect this is quite promising
because even the original model is
unavailable you're able to get very
close to what is available like for
example right if we look at say for 100
there are these hundred classes and as
as a rough measure to see how hard is
the task is you have hundred classes and
if we if you don't have the original
model available a random guess would be
1% accurate right so if we just randomly
choose one of the classes so here you
are able to get to this original
accuracy very close to that so you sorry
not yet yeah so that's a very good
question so I'll go it not for this
addition and subtraction but when I I
don't have the numbers on the slide but
with the image classification specific
encoder and and decoder so this addition
and subtraction will is not doing that
well on imagenet but on imagenet there
is also this another issue of you know
the training how we are doing training
so we are randomly choosing images when
when training and there the training
data set is too huge to so I think we
need better approaches for training this
I'll talk about in future work so a
better way of doing training yeah
exactly
yeah so if you if you think about it
writing on this this gold into
combinatorial space yeah yeah yeah but
we were pretty happy to see that even
with safar 100 it's doing pretty well
yeah you might not have asked for this
as discussion happens there
the first part that you described they
were actually not changing the
competition yeah for the accuracy would
hopefully stink that depends on their
encoder/decoder I guess but so you're
talking about up to what you want okay
what is the performance impact in terms
of latency especially for the case where
you say one figure in terms of oh how
much it adds hmm that's a good question
I don't have it on the slide Chuck do
you remember where you heard that the
encoder alone was at least a few times
so like higher than like a res there
like say we did resna 18 for the main
level our encoder that we were using
that got the highest accuracy fitting
with at least a few times like it took a
few times longer that's that is it going
back to the periscope yeah yeah yeah so
then yes I just came know triangular
eating this fabulous lady what is it
that's you all right yeah yeah that was
the main reason why we went ahead and
searched for this in this approach here
okay just wanted to show the accuracy on
the object localization task win which
is hard to show in a bar plot like that
so this is like one specific image
example and this is the ground truth
localization and this yellow box is the
available that is the original model
output and the the purple box is what is
the degraded mode that is when the
original model is unavailable and what
is reconstructed from the decoded oh
yeah so that so that's that's a very
good question right so it depends on the
application so we have had discussions
with several different teams so they
have different kind of applications in
some applications where you where
latency is very critical I know that
even learned that within Microsoft even
let I learned that you know there are
some teams let's say within being
it's so important the latency is so
critical that they are okay even doing
food replication yes exactly
yes yes that's yeah that's a very good
question so I will show one of the
evaluations here and more details are in
the paper and that is really application
dependent as to you know how much of the
how much redundancy is it worth it yes
yeah yeah that's what I will talk about
briefly and so that is basically
controlled by these parameters right
yeah
yeah have you tried this in practice so
you have a set up for this front-end
mm-hmm have you tried to send query
requests there is a you need to
essentially synchronize mm-hmm so a
couple of arrivals yeah okay you need
cannot exactly synchronize one has to
wait for the other and then you're right
so I'll do the straggler approach from
before yeah so so that's a very good
question so you need key inputs to
encode but one point is that the
original though the the path through the
original models need not wait in the
sense that there is no additional delay
introduced into the actual original
paths so you can pass it through the
original models and as you get care you
can encode so that path is not affected
but you're right that in order to use
this redundant path you need K of them
together but in a system with reasonable
throughput that's not a problem so this
is is the right way to think about this
they're in a system without this
capability I would fire up some
inference one of them might fail and
then I would have to pay the cost of
going through inference for that thing
again at that point so it's essentially
two times the cost of inference versus
this where we pay a slightly higher cost
to
recovered the output of the last one
mm-hmm but we've been able to overlap
the yes so being able to recover that we
nicely original correctly yeah so
basically like because this is a
proactive approach right so it uses the
redundant path in parallel yeah yeah so
we yeah so has to be within the circle
yes so if it is too low yeah yeah at
that point yes yes so we did so we so to
answer your question like we did
experiment as you mentioned actually
sending the queries with different
through ports so let me see if I have
that plot here or it isn't available in
the paper so we have evaluated with a
particular query different two ports and
doing it on the fly like how your system
game will be - right it might be yeah we
do know K cannot be thousand yeah so in
the sense that as I'll talk about like
it's okay for example k equal to in when
we have k equal to 2 R equal to 1 we
have 33% of them of the resources being
used for redundancy right so as you tune
it you just do yeah yeah yes yes it will
be smaller groups yes
yeah then you have five hundreds of
those yes yeah okay so so now overall
accuracy and this is where I'll have
different values of K and more
evaluation with different values of K is
available in the paper
okay so again overall accuracy accuracy
on the y-axis so higher is better and
this is where fu for different values is
coming in so on the x axis we have
different fractions being unavailable
and the yellow line is the available
accuracy because this fu doesn't affect
available so that's as you mean
everything is available and now first
this dashed blue line is for parity
models
with k equal to four now there so we
have like 20 percent of the total
systems being used for redundancy so k
equal to 4 are equal to 1 and now as we
decrease K so we are going so this is
for k equal to 3 and this is for k equal
to 2 so you can see the overall accuracy
improving right so so basically in in
other words if as we increase K accuracy
drops right so this goes back to the
question that was here like basically
you have as we encode more and more
images together there's more noise going
into the parity model when it has when
it has to contrast with the other images
okay so now very briefly which is it's
not really linear yeah it's not yes so
we have more evaluation in the paper
yes it's not really linear I think this
line linearity is is coming from the
fractions being unavailable the gap yeah
I know it's not removing it yeah yeah
and what ask is this oh yeah yeah yeah
so say fartin yeah yeah okay okay so
very quickly so so far had used Edition
encoder and the subtraction decoder but
these encoders and decoders could be
simple encoders and decoders but
specific to the classifier the inference
tasks at hand so for example for image
classification tasks we evaluated with
using an encoder which's downsizing the
images and just concatenating x' for
example let's take k equal to 4 and say
fart N and these are the 4 for input
images which were the queries and the
encoding the piratey image would be an
image where the same sized image 32 by
32 but four images put together so
downsize and concatenate excuse so this
help
improving accuracy because this is a now
specialized the encoder and decoder is
specialized for the inference task at a
time more details are available in the
paper there is also a concurrent work
which built on our approach of learning
based coded computation but specializing
for image classification which also
considered similar concatenation based
encoder okay so now I'll quickly discuss
evaluation of the latency so we are
evaluated on both CPU and GPU clusters
and as a baseline comparison we will use
a system with equal resources so that is
giving the same amount of redundancy
that is then the number of instances is
the same in both but in the baseline
those resources are used to serve the
queries original query so which means
that basically that the load on that
system is much lower
so basically latency would be better and
with varying query rates this is the
input throughput and a varying
background traffic ranging from very
lightweight inference traffic all the
way to a different varying number of
shuffles going on so I'll quickly go
through these and more details are
available in the paper which is also
available on archive right now
okay so now on CPU cluster now the
x-axis is the query rate this is you
know the part I was coming in a
different QPS and latency is on the
y-axis so now lower is better now to
specifically to Ricardo's question this
includes the latency of waiting for the
K queries and then encoding and so that
path the redundant path includes that
latency okay so now here are the tail
latencies 99.9 day latency the top line
is for the equal resources baseline and
this blue dotted line is what is from
the parity models approach
so we see a significant improvement in
99.9 day latency while keeping the
median similar so the knees to the the
bottom two lines are the medium for the
both of these equal resources baseline
and the piety models approach so we see
roughly around 50% reduction in the tail
latency while maintaining same median so
specifically we see the 99th percentile
getting closer to the median I don't
have exact numbers on that maybe they
are the same 30/30 vision yeah we can
look at the exact numbers of lines yeah
yeah so basically these types and
bringing more predictable latency so
basically bringing the tail latency down
while keeping the median latency similar
or even a little bit increase in the
median latency it's basically making the
entire end-to-end latency more
predictable oh yeah I think that more
like you know people who have access to
production servers would know better
yeah I'm writing down this question
oh yeah ii know this is not yeah that is
another yeah but that's a short-term the
other yeah that's a shorter talk so so
yeah so this is the we see similar
improvements on GPU cluster as well and
we against the improvements even when we
have a very light multi-tenancy
background which is another prediction
another clipper running with very low
query throughput okay so in summary for
part one I've talked about introducing
resiliency to machine learning inference
that is prediction serving systems using
coded computation and you know as you
recall the key challenge here is
handling the non-linearity of the neural
networks and our solution to this is
using a learning based approach for
coded computation that is designing
coded computation frameworks using
machine learning so this is a rich
design space lots to explore and the
encoders decoder and parity models this
is applicable for a variety of inference
tasks including classification speech
recognition image localization and we
have implemented it on clipper and
ensure the evaluation we have seen
significantly better degraded more
accuracy with no loss in the normal mode
and also it helps in making the latency
more predictable okay so very quickly
this space has opened up a very exciting
area within coded computation but
there's still lot more to do so
specifically as I was mentioning earlier
one of the interesting directions is to
see how to improve training for these
learning-based coded computation
approaches so currently we are using
random inputs from the data sets to
Train and there is combinatorial
explosion so especially for large data
sets
improving this learning task of the
training strategy would be very useful
and again as we discussed earlier
there's rich design space one could
think about designing better generic
encoders and decoders that could work
across
different inference tasks or you know
also design better task specific
encoders and decoders for popular tasks
or you know the better choices for the
parity models using neural architecture
search as I Maher was mentioning earlier
and also we're excited about exploring
the application of these approaches for
other workloads other than prediction
serving systems because this is a
fundamentally new approach for adding
redundant computation so it would be
very interesting to see what are the
workloads are amenable to this kind of
redundant computation in the interest of
time since we have we had already had
enough questions in between and quickly
go through the second part and then time
permitting we can come back ok so now in
the second part I'm going to talk about
resource efficient redundancy for
cluster storage systems and this work
appeared in Fast 2019 this is a joint
work with sourabh category with a joint
student with myself and Greg and Greg ok
so yes no I thinking is very proud about
the one moment it's ok
so story class history systems are the
storage subsystem of distributed systems
typically consisting of thousands to
millions of disks and they're built
incrementally over time as demand grows
right so failures are common in these
storage systems and disk failures are
measured using this metrical annualized
failure rates which roughly use expected
percentage of the disks that will fail
in a year but when more technically it's
like a conditional expectation that is
assuming the disk lives for a particular
age then what is its failure and a
popular for talents mechanism in storage
systems is redundancy and a few decades
ago data is to be fully replicated three
times or more but more recently due to
the deluge of data erasure coding is
almost always used in large-scale
storage systems so let's take a very
quick example to
come back again to the storage world an
erasure coding so let me take this
example of slightly different notation
here n equal to 14 k equal to 10 so k
still stands for number of data or the
original units and n stands for the
total now which is data plus parity so
in this example let's take these 10 data
units and add four pirate units because
n is 14 so 10 data and 4 parity and
these parity blocks now are some
functions of these data units and there
are different codes for example you
might have heard about reed-solomon code
which is very popular that's how you can
get to these parity blocks and each of
these 14 blocks are then stored on
different disks stored on different
servers and different failure domains
typical ok so now let's look into see
how this redundancy is configured in
these storage systems so the amount of
redundancy added is a function of these
parameters as we saw even in the first
part so it's a function of these N and K
for example if n is 14 and K is 10 the
raina C is 1.4 X so these parameters or
this redundancy is configured by
choosing these parameters to meet
constraints on durability and
availability for instance a popular
metric for durability is mean time to
data loss and for availability there are
various constraints on reconstruction
for example when a data unit is
unavailable what is the amount of work
that you have to do in order to
reconstruct it and these are chosen
based on an average failure rate
estimate across the disk fleet and these
configurations are typically chosen at
the time when the data is airasia coded
and is not modified thereafter so
essentially a key observation to make
here is that the current redundancy
configuration approaches are static
however the failure rates which
basically determine the amount of you
know durability or the availability that
you get are not static in fact they are
very far from being star
so we performed a study on failure data
made available by online backup service
called back police and observed that
failure rates are in fact highly varying
so they vary across disc families for
example here these are the six disc
families in the back plays data set and
they're very highly and they vary over
time so this is a textbook plot of how
typical failure rate of describes or in
general commodity components follow so
this is called a bathtub curve where
there is some infancy where the failure
rate is high and then there is a lower
failure rate region which is called
useful life and then again the failure
rate goes up which is called wear out or
old age so so this is a textbook cope
and these this is the real curve from
the back place data set so this is an
accumulative AFR curve for one of the
difficulties in back plays data set and
we can roughly see there being you know
infancy useful life and wear out stages
and these are the failure rate curves
over time for all the six different disk
families in the backplanes data set so
roughly we can see in the top three
there is a bottom characteristic and in
the bottom three they are still too
young they have not yet reached the wear
out stage yet okay so based on these
observations we're proposing a dynamic
approach for redundancy configuration in
cluster storage systems and the key idea
used to exploit reliability
heterogeneity by tailoring the
redundancy levels to the observed
failure rates of different disk groups
and overtime so let me give you an
illustration of what we mean by that so
let's take a disk group and and let's
say this is the time line now it is
deployed and we start monitoring it so
there is some infancy period and then it
goes through useful life and at some
stage the wear out starts and then the
failure rate starts increasing and it is
commissioned at some time so in order to
make a case for dynamic redundancy
configuration we are taking the most
conservative approach of using the
default fall tolerance scheme in the
infancy and wear out stage but in the
useful life region where the failure
rate is lower we use a disk group
specific fault tolerance scheme and this
this group specific fault tolerance City
scheme can be of lower redundancy
because the failure rate is lower and
this is where the cost savings or
storage space savings comes from so in
order to do this your proposed tool
which we call heterogeneity a very run
ANSI tuner or Hart for short which takes
durability and availability requirements
and the disk health monitoring data as
input and almost all large-scale cluster
storage systems already have mechanisms
in place to monitor disk health and the
tool consists of three units so one is
an anomaly detector a change point
detector and a redundancy tuner and I
will quickly go through what these are
and why we need it
so the for the anomaly detector so the
failure rates in the useful life period
is typically stable within reasonable
bounds however there could be external
factors that lead to bulk failures for
example rack power failure or you know
or human error or accidents and such
anomalies appear likely mature where out
I'm calling it anomalies not because
they are rare they happen often but
redundancy is not the approach to ID
resilience against such anomalies so
basically they need to be handled using
other approaches like careful placement
and other approaches so we don't want to
consider them as a failure rate increase
phenomena so that is why I'm calling it
as anomalies so and it's important for
us to identify these anomalies because
the benefits of redundancy tuning is
dependent on the length of the useful
life period so for example if this is
the
actual timeline where we have end of
infancy we're out and decommissioning
and we're using default schemes in
infancy and we're out but using a dis
group specific scheme use in the useful
life period if there is an anomaly in
between anomalous failure the useful
life period gets shrunk so we need to be
able to identify this so here is the
real AFR curve from the back plays data
set and there are actually three
anomalous jumps here which happened in
spikes due to simultaneous bulk failures
of hundreds of disks and we have later
confirmed with back plays that they are
really anomalous failure okay so this is
why we need an anomaly detector and now
next to change point detector so as I
was mentioning the cracks of this
tailoring redundancy is to identify
transitions from infancy to useful life
and useful life to wear out for disc
families and we and this is where the
change point detectors are needed so we
use an online change point detection
mechanism to identify these points and
here again caution is needed because the
reliability target can be missed
if we are hasty in declaring useful life
or if we are too delayed in declaring
the onset of wear out so there is a
trade-off between the benefits here and
and safety so and then iDEN as an added
safety measure we add additional buffer
to the estimated AFR in the useful life
period and even with an added buffer we
can get significant savings as I'll show
later okay and the last piece which is
the redundancy tuner basically chooses
the most space efficient arisia code
that can be chosen based on the
requirement that is still meeting the
durability and availability requirements
for the estimated useful life air form
so we've evaluated this on the back
placed data set which consists of
hundreds of thousands of disks
belonging to their production cluster
which is these discs actually constitute
more than 90% of their entire class
roster system so it has six drive makes
models mostly this is the hundred
thousand or more discs there are others
which are much smaller so we don't
consider them in the evaluation and it
has more than five years of failure data
so in the in the plots that I'm going to
show will use the following methodology
so in heart we have used so far like
off-the-shelf anomaly detectors and the
change point detectors they work fine
and the reliability target is chosen
based on the highest AFR scheme so
basically we need some target for their
ability when choosing the group specific
fault tolerance scheme so in the plot
that I'm going to show we will choose
the one family with the highest AFR and
say that's the target because that's how
the system it has to meet that so right
so that's the target and the disk group
specific fault tolerance schemes are
chosen to meet the following constraints
so one is you want to be able to
tolerate as many failures as the default
scheme and there's an upper bound on the
stripe width K this is for availability
that is when something is unavailable
you don't want to touch - why
okay so for this specific data set s 4
is a family of disks is the highest AFR
so we will use that as the target which
has 4% AFR in the useful life period and
this so this is going to be the default
scheme so the default scheme always
meets the empty TDL target for this s
for family of disks and the upper bond
I'll use in the plots is twice twice the
value of K that is allowed for default
anyway this is not fundamental any
constraints that the system
administrator has can be put in and we
evaluated it on multiple default options
so these two are the ones that are
specifically shown here and these are
the two published number
from Google and Facebook yeah when you
go from one redundancy scheme to another
yeah then you have to move a lot of data
oh that's a very good question and I
will come to that yeah so you don't have
to move you'll have to change the
erasure code that you are employing so
there is like conversion that needs to
happen so there is overhead yes when the
normally happens yeah you said well I'm
gonna assume that there's the well has
started no look we we don't want to
assume so that is very you'll detect so
basically the anomaly detector processes
the failure data and it removes out such
anomalies and it basically in
determining the useful life when it ends
and what's the AFR those are not
considered yes yes yeah okay so this is
a one this is one of the disk families
within the back place data set and the
black the red curve is the raw AFR curve
and the black curve is after curations
there are some small anomalous things
here this is a huge group of disks for
the specific family and the grey line
the grey region is the identified useful
life so this is the infant mortality end
and this is the old age this is
identified by the change point detector
and the dotted line is the AFR value
which is the AFR at the beginning of the
useful life period plus the buffer that
we have added and for wear out we have
being very conservative in this in these
plots as soon as the determined AFR is
above the threshold will declare wear
out okay so very quickly for the default
scheme n equal to 90 equal to 6 which is
six data three parodies which is
a small storage overhead already which
is only 1.5 X and infancy uses 96 we're
out uses 96 and this group specific
scheme is used only in the useful life
and in this plot y axis is the disk
space savings and the x axis is
different scoops so if you recall s4 was
the baseline that is we are not changing
the scheme for s4
that's the highest failure rate group
that uses the default scheme and that's
the target amplitude DL and 4-h for a
which is another disk group we have
about 16 percent savings in the disk
space when you use it a specific scheme
for that group for the determined F R
and the scheme used is K equal to 12 n
is equal to 15 for that that's what the
redundancy tuner chooses and for another
disk group about 13 percent savings and
we have similarly if we look at the 1410
default scheme which is even smaller
storage overhead of only one point 4x we
have about 14 percent and 11 percent
space savings so overall we have about
11 percent to 16 percent storage space
savings even in the space optimized that
is already using a ratio called storage
systems and these numbers will look
modest they translate to significant
cost savings in large-scale systems so
in summary we have proposed dynamic
redundancy configuration mechanism for
cluster storage systems for exploiting
this heterogeneity in reliability of
disks in large scale systems by
tailoring the residency schemes to
absorb failure rates and changing them
over time and on evaluation of the back
on the back please data set we saw that
it provides significant space savings
and this basically established the
potential for dynamic redundancy
configuration and we have seen
significant interest from the industry
and NetApp and Google have actually
shared their failure data with us which
we are working on right now so this is
just the beginning
and there again lot of interesting open
problems to study here so one of the
directions is the statistical study of
these AFR curves
estimation and the bounds currently the
bounds that we have require a large
number of discs to get the confidence on
the fr curves but they are loose I think
so we if we do most ematic statistical
study we can get the bounds much tighter
which means that we can start using
tailoring for even for smaller disk
number of disks and also another very
important direction is what the question
Ricardo asked is about the overhead of
redundancy scheme conversion so that is
not free that is it incurs huge amount
of disk i/o especially when changing the
array shakur configuration because thank
you if there is no no better mechanism
in place you have to re-encode all the
data which is a lot of i/o and cpu so so
we are looking into both systems
solution that is designing better
redundancy management so there are ways
in which you can preempt these
transitions and plan out such that that
overhead can be reduced and also on the
theory side we are looking at new class
of storage codes that make these
conversions efficient so while retaining
all other properties the same they can
help in making these transitions much
much lower so I'm super excited about
this we have a very recent paper up
online we are calling it convertible
codes that is they help in making
conversions more efficient and still
there are lot of questions to explore in
this space cool thank you and there'd be
happy to take any more questions offline
yeah yeah I'll be happy to chat more
yeah thank you yes thank you